in the flash I saw this grenade it hits
my shoulder and then it fell down
towards the ground and it detonated when
I got to the field Hospital a message
had come out to the base where this
field hospital was there was a bunch of
seals that were stationed at this base
and they didn't know necessarily how
badly injured we were and so out of like
respect all these seals in the middle of
the night put on their best uniforms and
walked into the tent and it dawned on me
that I didn't know the extent of my
injuries I thought that I was going to
be okay cuz I'm like I'm alive I got the
tourniquet on but I saw the looks on my
teammates faces and they're in their
uniforms and I'm like oh my God this
might be it I might die in here and I
remember trying to reassure them that I
wasn't going to die but I had no idea
and I remember that they looked at my
wounds and they were like yeah you were
very close I guess the way the shrapnel
went into my leg and my back just
narrowly missed fatal